Andy Cohen has never shied away from
asking others about babies what's the
hardest part about being a dad
which Atlanta lady has given you the
best baby gift so far when are you two
gonna have a baby beautiful but now the
tables have turned and he's got some
news of his own after many years of
careful deliberation fair amount of
prayers and the benefit of science if
all goes according to plan in about six
weeks time I am gonna become a father
[Applause]
who is carrying my future the 50 year
old talk show host made the surprise
announcement on Thursdays watch what
happens live he got a bit sentimental
when he revealed the news live on air
family means everything to me and having
one of my own is something that I have
wanted in my heart for my entire life
and though it's taken me longer than
most to get there I cannot wait for what
I envision will be the most rewarding
chapter yet Andy has been open about his
wish to become a father in 2016 he told
The Today Show he was feeling the itch I
think it's opening myself up to love in
a relationship and maybe a kid and I
think I'm closer to that spot than I
ever was and he insisted he doesn't
necessarily need a long-term
relationship to take the leap into
Parenthood you're like I can just do it
in April
Andy spoke with et about what's left on
his bucket list you've done so much you
know and accomplished so much but do you
have something in your head like okay so
I'm about to turn 50 but before I'm 51
this is what I want to do I would say I
mean I think that the rest of what I
need to do is all personal yeah you know
settling down with someone you know now
that I'm where I want to be
professionally I think I can relax and
kind of set up the rest of my life
[Music]